Our house has been hit with the dreaded gastro again.
So here's everything that I made to make my family feel better
because it's hard to stomach food after you've had gastro.
First I started off with a chicken soup.
My husband says that I make the best chicken soup he's ever had
and he's a hard critic to please.
So there it is on the stove.
Then the kids asked for McDonald's style pancakes.
So I thought instead of going out,
I just make them at home. Little bit of oil,
little bit of flour, egg,
vanilla, sugar,
milk and self raising flour.
And they turned out so good.
The kids love them. All of it.
Then I made a green smoothie.
This green smoothie
is something that I drink when I'm feeling really sick
and depleted. It replenishes you.
It honestly makes your body feel so good.
Then I made this green salad on the side to just have with our chips
and.